bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24
soy herminia fernández comenzamos
nos dirigimos a eeuu de la filtración de
un documento oficial confirma la
voluntad de la corte suprema de mayoría
conservadora de anular la jurisprudencia
de roe versus way que garantiza desde
hace 50 años el acceso al aborto en todo
el país si esta decisión es confirmada
de aquí a unas semanas tendría un
impacto sin precedentes en los 75
millones de mujeres en edad de procrear
en eeuu 26 estados conservadores dicen
estar listos para prohibir de inmediato
el aborto en cuanto a la corte suprema
lo anunció 50 años después de la
obtención del derecho al aborto bajo el
impulso de los republicanos eeuu está un
paso atrás y se transforma
progresivamente en desierto médico para
que las mujeres que quieren abortar una
realidad visible en ciertos lugares del
país tales como texas y oklahoma
nuestros corresponsales valeri de esfera
y pierre del oro nos conducen a esta
norteamérica post row
[Música]
cada mañana tiene lugar el mismo ritual
frente a esta clínica de abortos
son las mejores embarazadas de la tierra
las adoro
susan tiene una defensa infalible para
bloquear a los anti abortos que acampan
en el andén
ahogan el ruido de los manifestantes
puedo entregarle una biblia el perdón es
posible incluso tras un aborto
cada vehículo es flanqueado por los
manifestantes de un lado de los
voluntarios con chaleco arco iris del
otro
usted la joven de misisipí venga a orar
con nuestro pastor
hola estoy con la clínica no estoy con
esa gente
succión es lo que se llama en la jerga
buena acompañante venga la acompaño
acompaña a las mujeres que vienen a
abortar para protegerlas y con
frecuencia transmitirles confianza va a
haber van a empezar a gritar pero le
hablaré de cualquier cosa el clima sus
zapatos sólo para cubrir sus gritos la
wii mentes clínic de tulsa es uno de los
últimos centros de aborto abierto en el
estado de oklahoma pero la mayoría de
los pacientes ahora vienen del estado
vecino texas donde desde el otoño pasado
el aborto está prohibido después de seis
semanas de embarazo incluso en caso de
violación o incesto
desde el primero de septiembre cuando la
ley entró en vigor
nuestro volumen de pacientes se duplicó
prácticamente típico de costumbre
recibíamos unos 20 pacientes diarios
ahora 40 a 60 días de la noche a la
mañana oklahoma se volvió un refugio
para estas texanas que quieren abortar
tal como cierra de 18 años esta luna
cuenta con dos trabajos para ayudar a su
familia y recorrido 6 horas en carretera
durante la noche tras su turno nocturno
en amazon en texas
porque estoy en el límite el corazón no
late aún pero tengo 5 semanas y 6 días
estas últimas semanas han sido duras
para mi cuerpo no me imagino vivir esto
durante nueve meses
su prima le insistió para acompañarla es
el único miembro de su familia que está
al tanto
busco millones de clínicas toneladas me
llamó llorando porque todas estaban
reservadas ella no lograba encontrar
cita y algunas eran muy costosas
estaba muy estresada y con rabia y lee
le comparte su desazón con 19 años se
volvió madre hace un mes
no pude abortar porque cuando me di
cuenta de que estaba embarazada
la prohibición acababa de pasar en texas
entonces no pude abortar y no podía
viajar tuve que quedarme con él
cierre gasto 250 dólares en gasolina y
ortega y la píldora abortiva cuesta en
promedio 600 dólares y no es reembolsada
por el seguro social en eeuu en la sala
de espera decenas de mujeres esperan
poder abortar
tifón y la enfermera jefe hace horas
extras desde hace meses para recibirlas
a todas pero un nuevo golpe contra el
personal de la clínica oklahoma acaba de
hacer pasar una ley calcada sobre la de
texas y con efecto inmediato
desmoralizada a tiffany no sabe cómo
anunciar solo a sus pacientes
lo siento chicas no puedo hacer nada hoy
la ley acaba de pasar y el aborto ahora
es ilegal hablamos de mujeres que
viajaron desde texas kansas oklahoma
arkansas de todas partes y ahora a qué
lugar irán para abortar puedo contar con
los dedos de una mano la cantidad de
clínicas en los estados alrededores es
una locura
y el gobernador de oklahoma va aún más
lejos a partir de agosto a hacer un
aborto será considerado como un crimen
castigado con 10 años de cárcel y varios
miles de euros de multa
es profundamente desmotivante
sabemos que mujeres desesperadas se
encuentran soluciones de esperanzas hay
mujeres que morirán muy bien gota e
afuera los pro y antiaborto están más
que divididos y la atención aumenta
rápidamente
para saberlo
[Música]
esto es una persona no ves que es un ser
humano susan
respira
entonces el hecho de respirar lo que te
hace humana te pregunta si ya respiro
está en la biblia uno se vuelve humano
tras la primera respiración
lo único que quiere es gritar y
despreciar la vida de este ser humano
porque es un ser humano
esta lucha ideológica se volvió en unos
cuantos decenios una cruzada política
ronald reagan fue uno de los primeros
gobernadores del país que legalizó el
aborto de su estado california en 1967
seis años antes de la jurisprudencia roe
versus wade que transforma el aborto en
legal a nivel federal pero para alcanzar
la elección presidencial de 1980 regan
quiere movilizar el voto evangélico
retrocede entonces y se declara anti
aborto
we must
be part
desde entonces los republicanos han
mantenido dicha línea ideológica en el
2016 para hacerse elegir donald trump
les prometió a los evangelistas hacer
prohibir el aborto
en my
life
donald trump sostuvo su promesa y
durante su mandato nombró a tres jueces
en la corte suprema donde ahora los
conservadores son mayoría por primera
vez desde hace cincuenta años la
institución se declara favorable a la
anulación de la jurisprudencia roe
versus wade
lo que le daría el poder de decisión a
cada estado
26 estados conservadores dicen estar
listos para prohibir de inmediato el
aborto desde el anuncio de la decisión
de la corte suprema
los eeuu se volverían entonces un
desierto médico para las mujeres que
desean abortar una realidad tangible en
ciertas partes del país tales como texas
en houston desde hace varios meses la
clínica de planeación familiar está
completamente vacía el personal ayuda a
las pacientes a viajar desde que la ley
entró en vigor estamos obligados a
rechazar pacientes y ayudarlas a
abandonar el estado
las pacientes abandonaron el lugar desde
la entrada en vigor del sub-8 apodada la
ley del latido del corazón prohíbe el
aborto en cuanto una pulsación es
detectada cuando la mayoría de las
mujeres aún no saben que están
embarazadas
lo que ve en la ecografía son
pulsaciones de células que se volverán
luego un corazón pero no se trata aún de
una actividad cardíaca sin embargo esta
ley dice que si se perciben latidos esta
persona ya no puede abortar en texas y
es muy triste decirle eso a las
pacientes cuando están listas para ser
atendidas
de las 40 clínicas de aborto en texas
sólo quedan 20 abiertas
pero los evangelistas están decididos a
prohibir totalmente el aborto
han hecho de texas un laboratorio de
ideas muy conservadoras
mark dixon las pruebas en el terreno
este pastor de 36 años participó en la
elaboración de la sub-8 una ley temible
porque esquiva la ley federal y le da el
poder a los ciudadanos
y el mecanismo de vigilancia ciudadana
significa que cualquier ciudadano puede
demandar en el ámbito civil a cualquier
persona que hace un aborto o ayuda a una
mujer a tener acceso a él
en caso de condena el delator recibe
diez mil dólares de indemnización
marc retomo este principio pero a nivel
local
desde hace dos años recorre el país de
ciudad en ciudad para que pasen
reglamentos que prohíban totalmente el
aborto
centerfield voto por leo no también y
espero que esta noche mal que se la
adoptar a estas decisiones prohíben el
aborto desde la concepción al contrario
de la sub-8 que lo prohíbe sólo en
cuanto aparece un latido de corazón
[Música]
ese día trata de convencer a la asamblea
municipal de márquez texas de 250
habitantes
dónde
declaro esta sesión abierta gracias a
todos por estar aquí voy a empezar con
una oración
y
mi
agenda número 22 ciudades santuario para
los no nacidos
y desde el primero de septiembre ningún
bebé ha sido abortado en el estado de
texas gloria a dios por ello pero la
vida empieza en la concepción de hecho
el partido republicano de texas motiva
en su página que las ciudades hagan
pasar decisiones que prohíban totalmente
el aborto
aquí no hay clínica sabe
es una medida preventiva
sí claro que sí
el año pasado la administración baiden
se comprometió a dar acceso al aborto en
todas las ciudades del país
marc espero también bloquear la ofensiva
de la administración vaivén que
desreguló la píldora abortiva ahora
accesible por correo
estas decisiones garantizan que la
píldora abortiva
sea considerada como contrabando
no podrá ser enviada por correo
todo el mundo es favorable
perfecto es un hecho
unánimemente el pueblo de márquez se
volvió un santuario anti aborto
estoy contra el aborto estoy contenta de
que hayan venido y me hayan contactado
porque pienso que era la voluntad de
dios
márquez se volvió entonces la 48ª ciudad
en el país que prohíbe el aborto y la
43ª in texas
incluso si romper sus wait no es anulado
hemos encontrado la manera de detener el
aborto ciudad por ciudad
y lo seguiremos haciendo
j
en todos los frentes la ofensiva
antiaborto gana terreno en eeuu
[Música]
[Aplausos]
tras haber considerado el derecho al
aborto como una conquista los demócratas
tratan de contraatacar con el 58% de la
población favorable al derecho al aborto
los demócratas esperan movilizar a los
norteamericanos en las elecciones de
media legislatura
hasta que reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para visualizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]